well i hope there you know of course
absolute tragedy if anyone is in that
situation uh but we have protected
winter fuel payments i've made lots of
different difficult decisions which
people have rightly asked me questions
about why they were necessary but i
didn't didn't take the decision
to cut the winter fuel payments
precisely because i don't want to see
old people struggling with their fuel
bills we've also increased the state
pension every year triple locked the
state pension so
pensioners now get almost a thousand
pounds more
a year because of the increases in the
basic state pension and people say to me
oh you're just helping the older people
in our society but i would say this
first of all these are people who worked
hard all their lives made a massive
contribution to our society have the
least opportunity to vary their income
and second i have taken a difficult
decision on the pension age
to say that should start going up in
line with life expectancy because i'd
rather have generous pensions generous
heating allowances for people
and and not have to cut those but just
make sure we can afford it as a country
by increasing the pension age so this is
all part of my approach which has been
to try and take the big long-term
decisions we need for our country and i
think older people in this country and
indeed more generally the country as a
whole is in a fundamentally stronger
position than it was five years ago
we're going to push on to shauna